we've been looking at cryptography by
now is sort of understanding the idea of
taking a text punching it through a
mathematical algorithm and getting a
ciphertext out the other end right like
search now last time we looked at a
particular way of encrypting information
a particular system for you're going
through mathematically and turning a
message into something which is
completely undecipherable well not
completely but unless you know the key
what was the way what was the method
called you remember that it was an
acronym it was the it was the RSA
cryptosystem that's what we looked at
and one of the reasons why it was so
powerful is because it was not symmetric
cryptography
it wasn't symmetric you needed to
separate piece of information to encrypt
something and then to decrypt it right
and you couldn't easily work out one
from the other
okay so that was really really cool now
the piece of maps that really under code
that was this prime numbers right prime
numbers are a big deal and what's kind
of funny about them is that prime
numbers they come with their a topic
called number theory okay now number
theory is what I call our kind of pure
math so it's not applied it doesn't have
to do with physical situations it's all
just kind of playing around which is why
some mathematicians call it they call it
recreational maths which are maybe for
some of you you like that's two words
that shouldn't be in the same sentence
together but all the same the point is
that they're not doing this maths for
work like I need to calculate the
strength of this bridge and what
material I'll need to do otherwise you
know the cars will all fall off into the
sea like that it's not thinking of a
real-world application it's just for
recreation but after doing all of this
work in this and working out all these
things about prime numbers the
applications
but have been incredible practical right
the benefits of society's been enormous
every second billions of messages being
sent around the world all encrypted in
this way right the internet all kinds of
digital status security it all relies
over this recreational bats okay so
we're going to spend a bit of time T
naught prime numbers right now help me
remember when we were doing the RSA
cryptosystem there were some ingredients
that went into it in order to generate
the public key and the private key by
all the lock and key if you like so you
might remember that there was a pair of
numbers each time and I think the
example we looked at was 5 14 and 11 14
now I want you to remember this is
viewing it from the outside oh this is
what it what the keys look like after
everything's finished but there was a
mathematical process that went into
creating these numbers how do we do what
was the starting point
excellent I have to choose we call them
P and Q two prime numbers and then you
put them together okay you multiply them
that's how I got 14 because our numbers
were 2 and 7 and then off you go
everything kind of unfolded from there
so therefore it kind of stands to reason
that if you've got this prime number
right like you kind of need new prime
numbers every time you want to send
messages right if you want them to be
secure because I don't want everyone to
be sharing the same numbers then you'll
all be able to read each other's
messages and that's kind of not a good
thing so the question becomes well how
many prime numbers are there how many
prime numbers are there now what do your
instincts say what do you think is the
number of prime numbers that exist
okay now we got we've got a few options
okay we have few options when the
options I know it was infinite okay I
heard that there's an option
I guess the opposite would be there's
some finite number right there's a third
option which is we don't know we don't
know whether it's finite or infinite
because you know if there are trillions
of these numbers we can go and have a
look through them and we can keep on
searching and searching and not get to
be in for a very long time but it's
still not infinite trillions and
trillions it is not infinite might even
close so it's one of these three answers
so I am going to show you but actually
there is a proof for this there is a
proof for which one of these options it
is I'm going to show you okay and then
you'll see by the end which the option
okay so here's your son painting which
is Euclid's proof for prime numbers I'm
not going to tell you the exact name of
the proof because that would kind of
give away what the answer is
yeah can you wait about three minutes
just if you don't mean you you kids
prefer plans numbers works like this it
just says suppose suppose we'd sit up
suppose someone comes to you and they
say look I have I've worked out all of
the prime numbers here they are all
written down I have gotten a piece of
paper or many many piece of paper a set
or all of the prime numbers okay so
let's say suppose PE right is the set of
or prime numbers okay so we can actually
start to write out some of this right
these are set notation
okay the first prime number of course is
2 it's not 1 and there by the way there
is actually like it's not arbitrary but
it's not 1 there's a very important
reason why it starts with 2 you can see
on that later on if you're curious okay
to 5 so just suppose he actually rather
does not all the way to the end suppose
it does actually end at some kind of
number right so let's call that final
number X where X is the final point or
the line is right okay so I've got this
list and I bring it to you and I say
look I've got them all go on prove me
wrong we can this is how you can do it
okay just as a thought experiment okay
suppose that you know this this list
here what I've got listed yeah suppose I
said 11 was the last prime number
suppose I said 11 was X okay clearly
it's not you know there and more but we
could rehearse this with X is some much
larger number that you're not sure if
it's the last one and we can still do it
it's just that the maths is a bit harder
to follow okay so suppose you have all
of these what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take every member every element
in set P take every element
and what I want is I'm gonna work out
the product of the whole lot okay in
this case 2 by 3 5 5 5 7 by 11 okay and
find the product okay now this number is
something we can actually calculate
that's why I chose such a small number
okay so you get your calculator and we
have a number really Wow okay two
thousand three hundred and twenty that
was it okay right okay yeah sure all
right I'll take you which work right now
so you got ten in there cool what it
hasn't so here's what I'm going to do
right this number this number clearly is
not prior right because look it has it
has five factors okay
aha but now I'm going to add one then at
once
all right so here you go here's our
product of all the numbers in this set
of prime numbers now have a look at this
number I've just added one to the
product of all of your primes okay
the curious thing about this number once
I've added one is that well let's think
of these numbers that I've got here
right I can divide 2310 I can divide it
evenly by all of these numbers right but
this number cannot be divided evenly by
any of these why not I don't even have
to test it I already know why not it's
cuz I added one so what's gonna happen
when I divide I'm gonna get a remainder
on time right in fact using the language
that we already know right I can say 2 3
1 1 mod or anything in here any of those
numbers pick one next right any of those
numbers it's going to be equal to 1
every single time right because you'll
add them up and you'll only ever get the
2310 not quite it's a different reason
so that has something to do with it so
what have I just established right it's
like oh you came to me with the list of
primes or I came to you with list of
crimes but what we've just shown is that
there's a number that's missing okay so
your original list right P he cannot be
the set of all prime numbers because
you're missing one
we're missing one then of course you can
say well well maybe that's the last one
but now it's not because what would we
do you do it all over again you're going
this by this by this by this by this and
maybe that one and you've got hey presto
a new prime okay so this is actually not
just you guys prefer prime numbers
this is Euclid's proof to the fact that
there is an infinite number of prime
numbers
okay it's not just that we think it is
kind of not sure look by the she logic
of it and it's the tower that's right
it's proven no matter how many how big
your number is would always go through
this exercise and get a new prime pretty
cool